We're asked: Do the points
on the graph
below represent a function?
Now, before even attempting to
do this problem, let's just
remind ourselves what they
mean by a function.
A function literally just takes
some input, and it's
usually considered x,
some number x, but
it takes some input.
Let me do it in a
darker color.
So it takes some input, let's
call it x, and then it does
something on it or it maps
it to another value.
So you take your function, your
function takes x as an
input and then it outputs a
unique value or it says I
don't know what to do with x.
If it outputs a unique value,
that value is f of x.
Or another way to think about
it, maybe we could say that
value is y, and you could
say that y is equal to
a function of x.
You give me an x and then the
function does what it needs to
do on the x and then
it outputs a y.
Either way to visualize it.
This function either has to say
let me give you a y and
one unique y, or it'll
say I'm undefined.
I don't know what to
do with that x.
A function cannot give you two
different y's for the same x.
That would just make it hard to
specify what to map x to.
So when they ask us do the
points on the graph below
represent a function, we just
really have to make sure that
for every x-value, there's only
one y-value that it is
being mapped to, or for any
x-value, that it's undefined.
For example, at 6, they have not
defined-- and let me label
the axes just to be careful.
This is the x-axis.
This is the y or the y is
equal to f of x axis.
So if you tried to put
6 into this proposed
function, it's undefined.
They haven't told us what
y would be equal here.
That's completely cool.
Over here, if you put negative
1 in this proposed function,
it produces 3.
That's cool.
So far, this looks like it could
represent a function.
If it did, just based on this
point, you would say that f of
negative 1, because the input is
negative 1, is equal to 3.
Cool so far.
Now, when x is equal to 2-- so
for our proposed function,
when you input a 2, it will
output a negative 2.
Seems reasonable so far.
You input a 3, it'll
output a 2.
Still reasonable.
Now, when x is equal to 4, if we
want this to be a function,
what this graph is implying is
if you input x is equal to 4,
that the value of the function,
or the proposed
function, is both negative
1 and 5.
So this is saying that if you
take 4 into our function, into
our proposed function-- we
can't really call it a
function yet.
We're trying to see if we
can call it a function.
So if you put into our proposed
function that it
could get to negative 1 and/or
it could get to 5, this is
just not allowed.
It is mapping the value
4 to two values.
That is not allowed
for a function.
A function has to map from a
value to only one other value.
So the points on the graph
below do not represent a
function, so I'll
just write a no.